Ein absolutes horror-szenario ein atomunfall, im belgischen atomkraftwerk die
experten und expertinnen
bezweifeln die sicherheit des atommeilers
und das schon länger und auf deutscher seite der herstellung zwischen angst vor einem atomunfall knapp 70 kilometer vom umstrittenen belgischen
kernkraftwerk entfernt liegt daran und diana behörden verteilen jetzt jodtabletten für den fall des falles für einen atomunfall
Eine absolut klasse maßnahme wer die jodtabletten jetzt genau bekommt was sie bei einem
Atomunfall bewirken und noch weitere informationen, zu diesem fall jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Sein anfang september läuft die jod verteilung der behörden in aachen noch bis ende november
Können die einwohner in der nähe des dreiländerecks, im internet bezugsscheine für jodtabletten
beantragen und diese dann in apotheken einlösen ein anrecht auf die kostenlosen tabletten haben schwangere
Und stillende und alle menschen bis 45 jahre zudem muss, man
Im stadtgebiet aachen und offiziell gemeldet sein eine vergleichbare verteilungsaktion gab es bisher bundesweit nur in
Ausnahmefällen und nur in sehr begrenzten region absolut krass und den aachenern ist es ernst zitat je nachdem wie das genaue
szenario aussieht haben wir ganz große zweifel dass wir es schaffen jodtabletten reiste rechtzeitig zu verteilen das sagt der verantwortliche koordinator
Markus krämer damit meint er verschiedene faktoren die das horrorszenario
atomunfall
Maßgeblich beeinflussen wann passiert der unfall nachts oder tagsüber wie ist das wetter gibt es starken wind und regnet es und damit
im worst case nicht auch noch schnell und in panik
ausgabestellen für jodtabletten eingerichtet werden müssen sorgt man in aachen lieber vor und zwar nach der empfehlung der
strahlenschutzkommission denn die empfiehlt für gebiete der außenzone für den fall der freisetzung
radioaktiven jods infolge eines schweren reaktorunfalls die verteilung von jod tabletten
eingenommen werden sollen die tabletten aber nicht vorsorglich sondern erst wenn die
katastrophenschutzbehörde dazu auffordert das alles sei eine reine
vorsichtsmaßnahme heißt es in einer offiziellen broschüre der stadt trotzdem sagt das schon echt viel darüber aus
Wenn politik und verwaltung so eine maßnahme für nötig halten wir haben hier ja schon öfter über atomunfälle
berichtet und ihr alle kennt die fatalen konsequenzen
Die ein störfall haben kann doch was bringen in einem solchen fall jodtabletten
mediziner medizinerin sprechen von einer sogenannten
York blockade die hochkonzentrierten jod tabletten sollen also verhindern dass sich radioaktives
Jod in der menschlichen schilddrüse anlagert durch die einnahme wird das normale nicht
radioaktive jod gespeichert die schilddrüse ist
gesättigt vom gesunden jo die genaue dosierung ist für einzelne altersgruppen genau festgelegt erwachsene ab
46 jahren sondern allerdings keine jodtabletten einnehmen denn hier sei das risiko für schwere
schilddrüsenerkrankungen durch die tabletteneinnahme sehr hoch, höher sogar als das erkrankungsrisiko
Das herrscht wenn radioaktives iod aufgenommen wird die
Städteregion aachen rät
dieser altersgruppe sich individuell medizinisch dazu beraten zu lassen und klar ist auch die jodtabletten schützen eben nur die
schilddrüse andere organe können durch eine strahlenbelastung trotzdem geschädigt werden mittlerweile sind etwa
40.000 anträge für jeweils einen aachener haushalt eingegangen schätzungsweise wären damit rund
100.000 menschen mit jod versorgt anspruch haben insgesamt etwa
600.000 menschen
nach angaben der behörde haben sich wohl schon viele menschen vor
Der aktion jodtabletten in den apotheken geholt fest steht die arena haben angst und sind mehr als verunsichert immer wieder mal gibt es
katastrophenübungen gegen die drohende atomare verseuchung viele halten die verteilung der jodtabletten
als noch nicht ausreichend auch schutzkleidung gegen den radioaktiven staub sei wichtig die aachener fordern dass cios
Abgeschaltet wird denn nur das sei ein effektiver schutz für die bevölkerung doch bisher ohne erfolg ihr problem wird nicht kleiner
Das atomkraftwerk die rund 65 kilometer hinter der deutschen grenze und in der nähe von lüttich eigentlich ein unscheinbarer kasten
Mit drei druckwasser reaktoren gebaut ende der 60er jahre der erste block ist seit
1975 in betrieb doch die sicherheitssysteme sind absolut überholt immer wieder kommt es, zu grösseren störfällen
zu größeren nach denen der reaktor für einige zeit vom netz genommen wird 2012 wurden risse in einem reaktorblock festgestellt 2014
explodierte ein transformator und 2002 kam es zur bislang schlimmsten störung ein ventil stand einige zeit offen
der druck viel ab und das kühlwasser verdampft eine kernschmelze
wurde durch die sicherheitssysteme verhindert eigentlich hatte man sich in belgien schon 2011 verständigt bis
2015 den atomausstieg zu schaffen doch berlin ist abhängig von der kernkraft ohne sie
Droht stromknappheit wenn er kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen
Dann, drücken wir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch neue über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit super gau cernavoda
Schildere ich den ablauf der tschernobyl katastrophe wenn ihr da mal einen überblick haben wollt ist dass das video der mann ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran